the language you use
about yourself when you're by yourself
is what will make or break
your self-esteem
when we talk to other people when we
post on instagram when we share our
lives we always wanted to to look good
and be amazing and be so positive right
most people's instagram stories are are
just all of these amazing highlights and
how beautiful my perfect life is and
then you go home and you're by yourself
and you look at yourself in the mirror
and people
you know cry themselves asleep
what's the message when you talk to
yourself
what's the message when you're alone
what are you saying about yourself when
you can start to fix that self-talk that
inner dialogue that starts to shift
everything inside you to then create
amazing things outside you
[Music]
i remember when i first got started
making youtube videos my cell talk
was
in conflict
because i had
my parents who i remember the voice you
know there's a picture of my parents
behind me on my wall in my office and
when people ask me what's my favorite
quote of all time it's it's what my
parents used to tell me that i'm evan
castrillo carmichael i could do anything
that i believe that i can
and that is a constant reminder that i
still today you know at 41 still use
still tell myself still remind myself of
like i am having australia carmichael i
can do anything that i believe that i
can
and it's helpful and valuable and what a
gift um so grateful for my parents for
that
when i was getting started on youtube
though the other voice that was in my
head was
you're introverted you're shy
you suck on camera
um anybody who makes videos has a big
ego
just needs to be famous
and so i really struggled with that
because i had competing voices in my
head
it wasn't even what other people were
telling me to do it was me myself when
i'm by myself thinking about myself
that constant inner struggle with the
voices in my head
left me
struggling left me making super slow
progress let's me start it and stop it
and started to stop and if you look at
my videos i started and then i took big
breaks and then i started again then i
took more big breaks and it wasn't until
i solved that inner conflict that i
started to get more results and i
started to be more
productive and i started to
stop stopping i started to stop stopping
i stopped procrastinating i just did it
because i wasn't so caught up in my head
and the discussion and the inner
dialogue and the voices and i just
replaced it with
better thinking about myself better
messages to myself
i think when you can do that your life
starts to change
because it's not other people's opinions
that we that really shape us it's
other people's opinions that then
influence our own self-talk then that's
what shape us
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe nation top 10.
hey it's nina carmichael and we made
these videos it's because you're
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you need that push by
surround yourself with the best so today
let's learn from one of the best my
husband evan carmichael and our take on
his top 10 rules for success enjoy
rule number two take responsibility
you are where you are
because of you because of the choices
you've made you are right now here stuck
where you're stuck it's not the
government's fault it's not the
economy's fault it's not the algorithm's
fault it's not your parents fault it's
not even your fault i'm not even here
talking about placing blame it's not
about who we're gonna blame it's about
taking the responsibility to fix it to
say i don't want to stay stuck here
where i am right now things have to
change this is not this is not my final
destination
i'm going places
you're going places and taking the
responsibility to make that change
happen where too many people just get
stuck up on the blame like while i'm
here because
well because of the economy or because
of the president or because my parents
are because my education because
whatever circumstances and we use that
as a valid excuse a reason
for why we won't take action
well it's not your fault and because
it's not your fault we have somebody to
blame and so that means we can just stay
stuck
and unfortunately that's where most
people are stuck they're stuck being
stuck
they're stuck placing blame they're
stuck
because it's easy because it's easier to
just shut up the world and go dive into
netflix and entertain yourself as
opposed to actually fixing the problem
when there are problems that show up in
life and that's gonna happen for
everybody the most common responses
people have are one to blame somebody
else because it's not your fault and two
to go dive into entertainment
as opposed to saying
i don't even care whose fault it is
but i'm gonna take responsibility for
where i'm at and i'm going to invest in
myself to flip from entertainment to
education so that changes can start to
happen because until you break that loop
until you break that cycle
you stay stuck and and it's comfortable
it's comfortable and it feels good to
know that it's not our fault but
ultimately you're not happy
the short term you're happy because you
can just put the blame on somebody else
but long term you're not happy you're
happy because you never get the growth
you never get the progress you never get
your goals you never accomplish your
dreams and you're you're stuck there
knowing that you're capable of more
i went through this very recently on my
youtube channel so
um one of the strategies that i've been
helping some of my friends with there's
one guy in particular who has blown up
blown up on youtube
thanks to one key strategy that i gave
him and i told this to him
maybe a year and a half ago and he
started applying it maybe six months ago
and you see channel popping up growing
faster than i'm growing
off of my strategy and
i finally came to the realization like
why am i not doing this for my own
channels i'm telling other people to do
it most people never take action but
this guy actually took action on it and
he's he's crushing me now doing this
stuff why are we not listening to our
own advice like why am i not doing the
same thing on my channel yet
and it came down to well i'm worried
about i'm worried about my team i'm
worried about how much extra work it is
i'm worried about
um
you know mostly about my team and like
how we've done things in the past and
changing things up and i finally came to
the realization that no things this has
to change
because if it if if i can't make this
work
then it's my fault this is my fault and
my team's livelihood is my
responsibility and i need to be
constantly growing and getting better
and if youtube's algorithm changes i
need to be on top of it and i need to be
guiding my team
in the right direction
because they rely on me for
their career and for their impact now
could they go get another job of course
but hopefully they like working with me
and the work that we're doing and feel
like they're they're valued and and what
they're creating is having an impact and
so
me being afraid
is not a good enough reason
and so it wasn't until i really owned
that to say this is
you know this maybe took a couple months
for me for really to sink in like
my own advice
is being used
for somebody to help them blow up and
we're not doing it because i'm afraid of
the impact that it's going to have
on my team and that can't be a good
enough reason
that can't be a good enough reason
because ultimately i'm doing a
disservice
to my team i'm doing the service to
myself and i'm doing a disservice to you
because the more people who can see
these videos the more
more belief we spread in the world the
more impact we have the more
people's lives change the more great
companies are built this is my mission
and so if i don't do it
then it's my fault
it's not youtube for changing it's not
it's not
anybody on my team for resisting it's me
it's my fault and so when when i finally
accepted that then you can move fast
then i messaged some of the key people
on my team said okay here's here's what
we need to start to do
and
i understand there are problems with
this so let's let's fix the problems
because this has to happen
and now we're doing it and now we're
moving quickly and you know hopefully
we'll start to see the results uh but it
wasn't until i accepted the
responsibility for it to say i'm not
going to stay stuck in this rut that
we're in
that thing start to change rule number
three switch your mindset you did not
ask for this painful situation you're
going through right now you did not ask
for this health issue for this work
issue for this environmental issue that
you didn't ask for this thing to happen
to you this is where we struggle because
you didn't cause this it's probably not
your fault right maybe it is your fault
but it's probably not your fault this
thing that's happened there's a lot that
happened to make this thing happen for
you right now and so it's so easy to get
stuck in the land of negativity why me
what was me why did this happen as
opposed to flipping to say it's the best
this thing that's happening to me right
now it's the best
when i broke my neck
i was on my tour i broke my neck what i
said was it's the best it's the best is
it actually good to break my neck
probably not but it's it's my chance to
show myself what i'm capable of
i remember being woken up so i passed
out i had a a concussion i fell on the
floor i woke up like i fainted i woke up
and i remember that the hospital
had sent uh their their ambulance and
also fire people showed up and
my circulation was getting shut off i
couldn't feel my arms i couldn't feel my
legs they're worried that i'm having a
heart attack and i remember
going through this in my head as i'm
explaining what's going on they asked me
if i was okay and i said i feel okay
but then i can't feel my arm i can't
feel my my right arm i can't feel my
legs i can't feel and most people would
be kind of freaking out at this point oh
my god i can't feel my arm you can't
feel my legs
and
i'm calmly explaining that oh i can't
feel my left hand right now i can't feel
my right hand right now and just walking
them through what's going on and in my
head this is why it's so important
whether this is actually true or not in
my head what i'm telling myself is this
is the best i am the greatest patient of
all time
as people are normally freaking out in
this moment i'm calm i'm explaining
what's going on i'm i'm amazing right
and i would never say that stuff out
loud but
that's what the voice is inside my head
this is the best this is me i'm amazing
let's go let's solve this problem and
what it does is when you're in that
negative situation
it switches you to a place of
possibility
if you are stuck in complaining and why
everything is so bad and why this
happened to me all you're doing is
perpetuating the negative situation
you're not actually solving anything
when you can flip it to say this is the
best
this is my chance to learn to grow to
improve to solve this to show myself
what i'm capable of what it does is it
puts you in a place of resourcefulness
it takes you from a place of
helplessness
into one of resourcefulness that then
allows you to go off and solve the
problem
that immediate thing that nobody asked
for that you would never wish upon your
worst enemy that's happened to you right
now it gives you the tools to actually
come out of it and so switching your
mindset telling yourself that it's the
best when you've got these moments of
pain and struggle and suffering where
you just want to blame the world and
complain and tell everybody how negative
it is you flip it
it's the best practice those three words
maybe you're facing that situation right
now maybe you're doing something you
hate right now or something if it's not
right now listen i promise you something
is coming
at some point that negativity is coming
for you
and so use that as inspiration it's the
best rule number four chase your dream
what do i do with my life
one of the most important questions that
i get asked over and over and over and
over again people are struggling with
what do i do with my life
you see your parents doing something you
see your friends doing something
you know that that's not the life that
you want but you're afraid of actually
chasing down your dreams you see people
living their life on instagram and it's
so beautiful and perfect
and you're worried that you're not gonna
measure up that you're not gonna live up
to it that if you try and do your thing
you're gonna fail
and so you're constantly stuck in this
what do i do with my life pull between
the safe life that everybody around you
is living and they want you to live for
yourself or the dream life that you know
you're capable of but you don't know
quite what it looks like what do i do
with my life
here's what i found you're gonna have
moments in your life where you have
absolute clarity
and equally you'll have moments in your
life where you have zero clue what to do
let's break those two down
when you have absolute clarity when you
know exactly what you want to do when it
feels right when you have momentum
the best thing you can do is put your
blinders on and go to work the best
thing you can do is shut down everything
else and get to work building your dream
we often hedge we often play small we
often don't put as much in because we're
afraid but when you have those moments
of clarity you have to go play a bigger
game you have to start betting on
yourself
right now i look at my youtube channels
as an example
this is a pretty special moment in time
and things are very well aligned for me
right now i mean been doing youtube for
12 years built up a lot of traction have
a lot of momentum been helping a lot of
my friends made a lot of new friends as
a result of the channel got into rooms
that otherwise i shouldn't be in because
of the success of my channels
and it's been a lot of work
and the early years did not pay off very
well at all i share on my instagram a
lot of my traction and you know first
five years of the channel
we didn't even have 10 000 subscribers
in the first five years and then we went
and hit you know next five years 2
million subscribers now passing 3
million subscribers on the main channel
but a lot of
a lot of slow slow slow growth
but right now
is a very special moment in time right
now i need to push harder on the youtube
channels right now we've launched i
don't know how many channels a lot of
channels we got a dozen channels plus
maybe at this point i need to be pushing
more on youtube this is a moment in time
this is
the window here is so wide open that i
need to jump through it because at some
point it will close and and i don't want
to look back on this moment and say i
wish i pushed harder i wish i wasn't
afraid i wish i did the thing that i
knew was right and we'll have it you'll
have those moments too in your life
where you just see it so clearly you you
have this vision you you see it all
working out but you're afraid to go
actually take the action you're afraid
to go all in on it you're afraid to do
what is necessary and then what ends up
happening is regret
because you'll be at the end of your
life or even 10 years later thinking
i knew it i saw it so clearly there was
this opportunity in front of me and i
wanted to do it i loved to do it but i
was too afraid and somebody went else
somebody else went off and made millions
of dollars off of my idea does that ever
happen to you somebody made millions off
of my idea
well no they just went and took action
when you were
sitting being afraid
and so when you have those moments of
clarity you have to push everything else
aside and go after that thing
even though it's scary even though it's
too big even though it feels beyond you
you have to go after that thing because
that's where your genius lies
and you either lean into your genius and
go change the world
or you live the rest of your life with
regret you have to force it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet designed specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five evaluate yourself where
are you stuck right now is it your
business is it your relationships is it
your career is it
where is it your mindset your health
habits like where do you feel
is the number one place that you're
stuck right now in your life where are
you stuck get really clear on that
because having that honest conversation
with yourself really matters that's how
you can start to make the change and the
point of this is not to say that you
suck and look at the the disaster you
made for yourself and i can't believe
you're not doing better this is not a
negative self-talk exercise this is a
we're going to have an honest evaluation
of where we are right now this is you
sitting down with you you can look in
the mirror you can journal you can go
for a walk whatever you need to do to
have that conversation with yourself but
figure out what is the number one area
that you feel stuck right now that you
don't want to be stuck in anymore that
if you're still stuck in the same spot
that you are in
right now one year from today you're
gonna be upset
you're gonna be upset that you missed an
opportunity that you've wasted another
year of your life so where is that
number one area that you feel stuck
right now get some clarity on it maybe
it comes right away maybe you gotta
digest it but get some clarity on that
because that that's the starting point
to making some changes rule number six
make that small tweak the fact that you
look at your calendar today tomorrow
next week and nothing excites you okay
great what can you shift and it may
require a wholesale change it may
require you doing some drastic thing but
more likely you could probably just do
one small shift
like just start building momentum just
start doing one little thing every day
to start to train yourself to start to
just push the ball a little bit forward
because often we
think we have to make some giant change
and the only answer is to move to mexico
and then it never happens because to
move to mexico takes you however many
you know months and budget and all this
stuff you get stuck in planning but
instead of doing
what's a small step what's a small tweak
that you can make to today's calendar
to inject more energy into it with
something that you're going to love
doing that will give you more energy
that then now you have energy for other
things as well right some kind of
immediate momentum rule number seven do
what you love
you can't be doing the stuff that you
hate
you have to find a way out it may not be
today it may not be right now may not be
this week but you have to find a way out
so if you're working for a boss that you
hate
long term you can't be doing that
anymore if you're in a business that you
hate and maybe you started the business
and you hate it long term you can't be
doing that anymore you will never win
doing work that you hate
people say well you have to do whatever
it takes but you won't you won't do
whatever it takes if you don't like the
thing
and you're going up against people
you're competing against people who love
the thing
they love it and for you it's just a
strategy and so
the key is you have to leave the things
that you don't love doing and leaning on
the things that you do and find a way to
use the thing that you love to then
bring value to other people so you can
have a real business so you can go make
an impact you can build the life that
that you deserve that your family
deserves and the people around you
deserve as well so if you don't love it
and worse if you hate it you have to
find a way out and that may not be today
this is where people get caught up in
the struggles like well i don't i don't
like it but i have no other plan okay
well we have to start working towards it
so that a year from today you're not in
the same spot
but today you have to go show up and
kick butt on the thing that is causing
all these problems for you so i look at
my youtube channels for example done
over ten thousand videos just crossed
three million subscribers on the main
channel woo thank you guys appreciate
you
i've been doing this for 12 years
april 2009
how how do i keep going how do i keep
making videos how do we how do we crank
out 10 000 videos plus and how have i
not burnt out have we not taken
time off
because i love it because this doesn't
work for me because i look forward to
this
because i look at my filming day which
is the tuesday when i make these videos
and i'm excited to make more content to
share with you guys to hopefully maybe
this today is the video that finally
sinks in for somebody for somebody
watching this video whether it's true or
not the message i tell myself is
somebody is going to watch this video
right here today this one and it's gonna
be the light bulb moment for them not
everybody but for one person that video
this one right now is gonna be the light
bulb moment for them that gives them the
big unlock and so i have to show up i
want to show up i'm excited to show up i
can't wait to show up
12 years keep making content and and as
long as i love it i'm going to keep
doing it and so this is why if you're
trying to do youtube just as a strategy
you're going up against people who love
the thing
so you're always going to lose
meanwhile there's something that you
love doing and that's where you need to
be long-term rule number eight spend
time with great people who are the
people who've done this thing
who are the people who are great
at this thing who are the people who you
look up to respect admire maybe they're
physical people humans that you can
touch and and have coffee with and have
a phone call and go meet uh and are in
your life or maybe they're people you've
never met yet and and you can learn from
them on youtube
on instagram on podcasts but who are the
people
that
are doing this thing they're great at it
the thing that you're struggling with
right now they're world class at it
and you want to try to find some time to
be around them more
you make it part of your daily ritual
now to be around them more if it's
somebody who's in your circle you're
trying to have a regular call with them
that may be a daily call for a while
maybe it's a weekly call maybe it's a
monthly coffee but you're trying to
spend more time with them and then you
supplement with
with regular content you start following
the people on youtube who make you feel
more of that who make you want to play a
bigger game you start following people
on instagram who lift you up who make
you feel the hope and possibility with
conscious intent you're picking who
you're surrounding yourself with and who
you let into your life based off of goal
number one
so goal number one is to have more
belief in yourself and the biggest
problem you have is you don't have
enough belief in yourself great you can
definitely supplement with a lot of my
content i mean at least that's the
intent with every video i make i'm
trying to inject more belief into people
into myself as well as other people if
your number one goal from step number
one is you want to
uh have better health
great
who are the channels that you need to
subscribe to
to
make you feel if you're watching people
who are constantly living healthy who
are working out who are doing the right
diet who are taking care of themselves
who value themselves if you're
constantly around that
they will lift you up they will make you
more healthy not just because of the
strategies the strategies alone aren't
aren't much it's the it's the
environment it's the mindset it's the
belief by being around these people they
automatically pull you up they
automatically make you feel like it's
possible they automatically become a
part of your daily and they push you
towards having the courage to do the
thing that you want to do rule number
nine have a reminder have a reminder
system in your life constantly
what are the things because you're
feeling it right now hopefully if you're
watching you're feeling it right now
you're feeling excited right now you're
going to make a change right now and
then tomorrow you're going to fall back
to who you used to be so what what do
you need in your environment what do you
need in your habits in your daily
routines to remind you you need to
remind your system so it can become more
automatic that it doesn't rely on your
self-will and your discipline constantly
that it gets introduced to you
constantly whether that's
uh youtube videos why hey espresso five
days a week every morning i'm here let's
go here's a new video for you uh if it's
edmylette's channel or tony robbins
channel or or oprah winfrey's videos
like whoever or if it's books or
podcasts if it's your physical
environment if it's uh
morning intention like just figure it
out for yourself
and schedule it in
schedule in the reminders
schedule in the intentionality so that
this doesn't just become a one-off
moment but that it's a daily reminder
it's a daily consistency it's daily
momentum because you need that you make
that change happen you do those three
things
you you do the audit on your life you
take immediate action and you schedule
in that consistency
your life changes
your life changes
and then the concept of swimming forever
or beyond the mountains more mountains
doesn't feel overwhelming doesn't feel
scary doesn't feel impossible it's
invigorating
it's amazing
it's awesome
because you're on a mission
have you got a vision for a better world
and for a better you and now you're
actually going to show up
and make that happen rule number 10 the
last one before our very special bonus
clip give yourself exposure i don't know
what to do next all i know is i don't
want to be doing what i'm doing right
now is that what happened to you
you know that you don't like your
current life you know that you don't
like your current habits you know that
you don't like your current schedule
your routine what you're doing who
you're hanging with you know you don't
like any of that stuff but you don't
know what to do to change it has that
happen
if that's you right now
then your immediate goal
is the exact opposite it's not to go all
in on one thing it's to try many things
to give yourself a lot of exposure to
say yes to as many things as possible
that are inside your code of ethics
right don't go
steal something from a store because
it's something new
right that are inside your code of
ethics
to taste the test to try to explore to
find the thing that might be the next
thing for you
and to lower the barrier
for just getting started
so i went through this
in my website when i have my website a
lot of people don't know me from my
website because if you go to my website
now there's not that much there but i
used to have a hundred thousand plus
pages of content on my website and i was
playing the seo game and publishing tons
of content and and we had a lot of the
big name people
in entrepreneurship creating content for
our website
and i was selling ads off the site
and i realized at the beginning
i was all in at the beginning i loved it
i wanted to write i wanted to bring on
people i wanted to we had 5 000 people
or so writing for the website i loved it
it was all in i saw this moment in time
i was going for it and we quickly grew
the website but i found that as
maybe year three year four
i was starting to lose interest
wasn't exciting anymore
and i didn't know what else to do inside
the website to
bring that energy back
so i started to taste test explore other
things outside the website and one of
those experiments was youtube
one of those tests was me starting my
first youtube channel
and
i really sucked at it
you can go back and watch my old videos
it took me a long time to get half
decent in front of the camera i sucked
at it
i had no natural inclination for it
i told myself well i'm i'm an introvert
and i'm shy so i'm always gonna suck on
camera
but i realized i don't know i just i
liked it
i liked it i liked doing it i liked
making visual content instead of written
content because i'm a visual learner i
like the idea that
maybe there's somebody else out there
who'll watch my video and be inspired by
it and that maybe makes a shift for them
i never expected to be youtube famous
because at the time youtube famous
wasn't a thing nobody was youtube famous
especially in education
nobody was making long-form educational
videos it just didn't exist
and so i thought you know what i'll just
keep doing it because i love it that if
50 people 100 people watch this video
that's 1500 people who watch the video
that's maybe a couple lives change
because of me
being courageous enough at the time to
press record and make a video
and so that kept me that kept me going
and eventually i turned it into
something that then i shut down my
website and it went all in on youtube
and so
when you don't know what to do
[Music]
you need to get out of your typical
routine go for a walk go to go go drive
somewhere you've never been before take
an extra long shower like do the things
that help get you create creative ideas
and then whatever comes
whether it's start a youtube channel
start a podcast start writing a book
start singing a song start like whatever
ideas come to you they will probably
sound crazy
for someone like me it would be crazy to
have a youtube channel
for someone who doesn't like being in
front of the camera
who doesn't like seeing himself who who
thought that people who
filmed themselves had to have a huge ego
and be chasing fame and i didn't want
that
for someone like that
i would have never said never never that
i would have a hundred thousand
subscribers you know let alone three
million plus never i would have never
thought that was possible now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and just get motivated the science says
you have a 35 chance of actually
following through on your goals that's
not good enough no not for you believe
nation we got to do something but when
you write it down and you create a
specific plan of action for the next
week that number jumps to 91 chance of
you following through and when you
commit to somebody else like leaving a
comment on this video it jumps to 95 you
need to follow through on your goals so
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your specific plan
of action for the next week put it down
the comments below so i can celebrate
you
your brain does not want you to hit your
dreams your brain
is designed to keep you small to keep
you safe to keep you protected your
heart wants to create amazing things
your heart has big dreams your heart
sees a beautiful world and says i want
to go make something better and then you
wake up the next day
and your brain takes over and says you
can't do that
that's too risky that's too dangerous
stay small stay safe you didn't go to
school for that
and what ends up happening is this
constant back and forth between your
heart and your brain when you're getting
these motivated moments when you want to
do amazing things and then your brain
takes over again and keeps you small and
this is the path that so many
entrepreneurs go on this roller coaster
ride of up and down and up and down and
up and down and up and down
sound familiar
it's time to get off the roller coaster
and start making progress on your dreams
today's video i'm going to show you how
so
yesterday i got asked on my live stream
evan what's the most important part of
your daily routine
and so many people have so many
different daily routines and and it's
easy to do the things like drink a glass
of water in the morning go outside and
get some sunlight and you know all of
these things but the most important
thing for me is actually having my
intention for the day i've actually been
experimenting with writing it out the
day before so this is this is what i
wrote last night
of basically my entire schedule
and then more than just what i'm going
to do more than just what i'm going to
do it's how i want to feel what's my
intention going into it so if i look at
this i'm supposed to be recording and
espresso videos right now right that was
on my list 10 30 a.m record and espresso
videos it's right there and here get a
head start even though you don't want to
recording videos at the beginning is
always difficult for me there's a couple
reasons why i'm i'm shy i'm introverted
i don't crave the spotlight i don't like
being in front of the camera
i don't i don't i don't do it for ego
purposes
and also i'm afraid i'm afraid
because i want it to be great i want
this video to be the next best video i i
don't want to disappoint people my
number one fear is going to be that i'll
disappoint somebody and so every time
you make something you risk
disappointing somebody where it's easier
just to stay small stay safe don't make
anything today and so
it's on my list the to do right i think
a lot of you if you're watching this
video you probably have a list of
to-do's but how many of you are actually
doing the things on your list of to-do's
the hardest part off of just getting
started
already as i started recording this
video it's a lot easier to keep going
and recording more videos this is the
first one that i'm recording today
and so having that written down
get a head start even though you don't
want to
reminds me of who i want to be
and what i find so valuable about this
is i write this the night before
so the night before you know it's it's
11 o'clock at night i usually sit on the
floor and i review my calendar for the
next day and i write out what i'm going
to be doing and i've added how do i want
to feel what's my reminder to myself
before stepping into that task imagine
you're being your own high performance
coach sitting there telling yourself how
you want to feel remember your intention
before starting that next task
and i knew
okay evans is what you always do before
you make a video there's a little bit of
procrastination there's a little bit of
fear there's a little bit of slowness
there's a little bit of
not laziness but there's a little bit of
just apprehension before you get started
why because you don't want to start
because you're afraid because you don't
want to you don't disappoint people so i
write down that message again get a head
start even though you don't want to the
fastest way to accomplish anything is to
model someone who has already had the
same success that you are after you can
go around trying to figure out
everything by yourself trying to come up
with every new idea yourself and you
will slowly slowly make progress towards
your ideas but until you recognize that
success leaves clues that whatever the
thing is that you're trying to
accomplish has already been solved by
thousands and thousands of thousands of
people that all you need to do is model
their success until you realize that
you're going to constantly stay
struggling making slow progress knowing
that you're capable of more so i first
learned the power of my own success with
my first business where i was struggling
i was i was 19 20 i'm not making any
money 300 bucks a month low confidence
filled with self-doubt not getting
results you know i turned down high
paying jobs to do this thing and own 30
of a company that seemed to be going
nowhere and i told my partner that i
quit and the thing that saved me
when i hit my lowest point was i am not
the first person to try to solve this
problem before maybe my specific
scenario yes biotech software you know
from toronto who's done that before
nobody but a software company getting to
a million dollars somebody's done that
before
how about i just look at their success
and try to emulate it and so the only
person i could think of off the top of
my head was bill gates so i looked at
bill gates and how he got started and it
was through partnerships and i applied
that lesson to my business and in a
short amount of time had my first deal
for 13 and a half thousand dollars i
felt like a rich man you know i felt
like holy cow
and to go from 300 bucks a month and and
saying i quit to now having a deal in
place for 13 and a half k and more
important the strategy that i could use
again and again again was was life
changing for me
all because i modeled success and that
was again when i was 19 20 so now what
have i done for the past 20 years is
just model success what is my youtube
channel about what is this video about a
lot of the success why i have these
people behind me it's not for you it's
for me i want a model success they're
constantly pulling me up to a greater
spot whatever problem you have
has been solved not exactly the specific
minutia but by modeling bill gates it
took me 80 percent of the way
you still have to figure out that final
20 percent but most people are trying to
figure out the whole hundred that's the
problem
i was struggling when i was trying to
figure out the whole hundred all by
myself i just come up coming up with new
ideas new ways new innovation but
nothing worked
[Music]
all you have to do is figure out that
last 20
and so look to your heroes look to
potential mentors whether you know them
in person or not they've done it before
they can teach you success leaves clues
you don't have to go through this alone
and you can ramp up your success really
quickly how you think about the problem
is the problem most people are locked
into losing thinking finding all the
reasons why you won't win if you're the
ant think about how you can kill the
elephant if you're the elephant think
about how you can kill the ant the
problem is not the problem how you think
about the problem is the problem so i
used to think that introverts couldn't
win i used to think that to be a good
speaker to have a youtube channel to to
be an entrepreneur that introverts can't
win and for the longest time i hid
behind the faces on my website so before
even starting youtube i started on my
website it was called evancarmical.com
i didn't have a better name at the time
and i profiled different successful
entrepreneurs basically what i do on
youtube but on my website because i
wanted to share the stories model and
success saved my business and i wanted
to make it easier for other people to be
able to get success on their own as well
so learn who's done it apply those
strategies make it work for you and
let's go and so i always hid behind the
faces i remember my first banner i had
howard hughes a big howard hughes
oprah winfrey and a couple other people
and people kept asking me well where's
evan carmichael you know the website's
off your name you're putting this
together what's your story and i thought
well who cares about my story i mean
sure i built and sold my first business
but it's nothing compared to howard
hughes and oprah winfrey's people who've
done great things and it kept coming up
over and over and over again translate
that to my youtube channel
evan carmichael was still the number one
requested top ten and when i first
started doing top tens we did kanye west
shout out to kanye there on the wall and
then a bunch of other people people kept
asking for mine like well what do you
want mine you mean again what have i
done compared to kanye west and i always
hit behind the fact that i was an
introvert and so i don't want to share
my story nobody is interested i'm shy
i'm i'm the wallflower i don't go off
and try to make myself the center of
attention i don't like you know hanging
out with people
and so i had the story that introverts
can't win
it wasn't until i reframed it and
thought you know what introverts can win
in communications because we're better
listeners i'm a great listener as much
as you might think i love talking and
making these videos and seeing the
speeches that i do what i love doing
more than that is listening and i think
that's how you win as an introvert
because it's not about you just sharing
sharing sharing talk talk talk look at
me it's you're trying to help
and i've met some amazing introverts who
are on a huge mission and want to have a
big impact and have to fight with
themselves to get out of their comfort
zone and have the spotlight on them
instead of just being behind the scenes
but they're all great listeners they
become great communicators because
they're great listeners and so the
problem wasn't that
i'm an introvert the problem is how i
thought about the problem of being an
introvert why do you get depressed after
you accomplish a goal you celebrate a
goal for five minutes and then you're
sad why is that it's because you had the
wrong goal
your goal should not be to climb to the
top of the mountain because the only
spot left is to go down your goal should
be to climb forever you never stop
climbing you're on a mission you're
trying to save the world
stop asking when can i stop you don't
you don't want to you want to climb
forever you don't want to stop not now
not ever because you are on a mission so
one of my biggest fears is the aging
rock star i look at some of these rock
stars who
made it big when they're in their 20s or
30s and then as they get into their 40s
50s sometimes even 60s they're still
playing which is great they're still on
tour which is awesome but what are the
songs that they're singing the songs
that they're singing are still the ones
that they came up with when they're in
their 20s or thirties and i can't
imagine that i can't imagine coming up
with a video
in my twenties
did i was i under my twenties i was ten
years ago right april 2009
i was on nine wow i'm getting old april
2009 yes april 2009 so it was 29 when my
first video went up great if i'm still
showing that video all the time if i'm
still showing my 40th video then that's
the one that hit i just feel like
it's such a letdown i mean it's great
that you're still on tour it's great
that you're still being asked to to get
on stage but to sing the same songs over
and over and over again for me i'm not
trying to judge or say that they suck
for me i'm terrified of that i don't
want that to be me i don't want to think
of the video that i made last year is my
best video ever and all i'm going to do
for the rest of my life is just play
that same video over and over and over
and over again i want to climb forever
i want to challenge myself to come up
with new stories each time whenever
possible making these kind of videos i
want to always push the envelope i want
to always discover new formats i want to
always look at splitting up my channel
or bringing them all back together or
launching a course always always
something new always climbing
i don't see it as this mountaintop there
is no mountaintop you're on the
staircase and you're climbing forever
and you're never going to get to the top
you don't want to get to the top that's
that's sadness that's despair when
you've accomplished everything there is
to accomplish you hate your life that
sucks you celebrate this is what happens
for high achievers right you celebrate
for five minutes like man we did it and
then it's a big letdown when i crossed
two million subscribers on my youtube
channel a million subscribers i didn't
want to celebrate like because the day
to day is a celebration because this is
i'd rather this is celebration this
making this video right here this is my
celebration moment
the process the actual part of climbing
right i'm trying to get better every
single time six thousand videos later
still going when do i stop i don't i
want to make six million videos
right
my goal of hitting a billion
entrepreneurs i don't actually want to
hit a billion entrepreneurs i want to
have a goal so big that i never do it
and so i don't want to be that aging
rockstar i hope that when i'm 95 years
old
i may you know not have my mind totally
there my body might be giving up on me
but i'm hoping i'm hoping that i'm still
trying to push the envelope so try to do
more do my best and maybe if i get lazy
complacent slow if i start complaining
you catch me complaining when i'm 95
years old show me this video back show
me this video and say look look
you've become what you said you didn't
want to become
right hold me accountable i think as
soon as you stop growing you're dying
and i think that's why so many people
are unhappy because they've actually
stopped growing a long time ago and so
don't be the aging rock star i don't
want it for me i don't want it for you
either you are staying small because
you're afraid you're afraid of the worst
case scenario coming true losing having
no money and being embarrassed but you
know you're capable of more
you know the way that you're going about
doing things right now is nothing
compared to what you're capable of
unless you lose that scarcity mindset
you're always going to stay small
knowing that you are capable of more
today i'm going to show you how so one
of the easiest ways to get out of your
scarcity mindset is to go from idea to
action as soon as you get an idea you do
something about it and sometimes that
idea often that idea is going to be too
big too scary too crazy you can't do it
who are you to do this you don't have
the money resources time connections
energy
right all of that all of the excuses
that come into your head i like to teach
myself that as soon as i get an idea i
go do something
it may not work but you have genius
ideas trust him go do something most
people either have no idea who they are
and what they want or they do but they
don't have the courage and confidence to
chase it down if you don't know who you
are and what you want then that needs to
be your immediate priority that's the
single most important exercise that you
can do right now if you know what you
want but you're not chasing after it
having more confidence in who you are
will give you the courage to chase it
down either way i'm going to give you
the answers in this video so when i
first started making videos
i sucked
you can go back you can watch the first
one it was april
2009 over 10 years ago i sucked i was
nervous i was shy i was trying to
memorize lines i was sitting down i was
in a suit i was sweating i sucked it was
brutal
and making videos
isn't a logical choice for someone like
me i was introverted i still am i was
afraid of being in front of the camera
i'm looking into the lens and the the
red light went on and i went blank i was
trying to memorize my lines just on
paper if you saw me and you said what i
was good at and then put me in
in a situation where i'm making videos
said don't do that that's not for you
here's the thing
i liked it
i wasn't good at it but i liked it and
when you like something with enough
effort enough practice most things you
can be great at it
now i'm still on my journey i still have
a long way to go there's still people i
look up to guys like gary who are
crushing it and say i still have my
journey to get better on but i'm a lot
better than i was when i started
and now i'm off doing keynote speeches
and i'm getting flown out and getting
paid to speak in front of audiences and
i'm growing a channel with two million
subscribers and then these sub channels
on top of them it's crazy
because i was doing a thing that on
paper i wasn't supposed to be good at
but i just loved it and that's where the
self-awareness piece comes in because
you will get an idea to go off and try
something but you'll judge the idea and
you'll say i can't do this because i
don't have x and y and z and i'm not
good enough and tall enough and smart
enough for whatever enough right i'm not
enough
and then you play small for life and you
have uncertainty and you're walking on
quicksand and you end up being pulled
into making somebody else's dreams come
true instead of you watching chasing
your own version of your life down
because you're thinking about all the
reasons why you're not gonna win instead
of the eight why you will so take it
from me a guy who's introverted afraid
of the camera shy
doesn't like talking to people
if i can get here
so can you on your dreams i feel like
i'm always spending time with myself i'm
always talking to myself i'm always
reminding myself
of how awesome i am of
the ideas that i have are great and i
need to start acting on them i'm very
aware of my thoughts my feelings my
emotions and whenever it's not feeling
right
i switch
and i'll switch on a dime
as soon as as soon as this youtube
channel stops feeling
worth it
not fun anymore wrong energy i'm out and
i'll just leave it behind and move on
and go do something else
i think the same thing of of meditation
i haven't
been able to maintain
and find value in a meditation practice
because i think there's two there's two
sides of meditation and i've only
recently learned the difference
the first is about focus and presence
i'm always focused like i'm almost
always focused on presence i'm 85
in the moment focused and and 15
thinking about the future and zero
percent thinking backwards
somebody asked me that question how much
time do you spend past present future in
your day to day like zero about the past
that's why i have a poor memory mark
dreger says i have a poor memory
um i don't i just
don't live in the past
so i don't remember most things because
they don't matter to me
i don't they don't apply to me i'm not
i'm not thinking about even even when
you ask me how old i am i have to think
about the year
who cares
i was born in 1980
may 20th 1980.
how is that relevant because you want to
compare your journey to mine that i've
come so this far 39 and you made it this
far at 24 or 54 or whatever i don't know
i just don't think that way i think zero
going backwards and then most of the
time is present and and a little bit
future forward thinking
whenever i'm feeling
stuck
i'll spend more time with myself i'll if
i feel like i need to go for a walk i'll
go for a walk
it's just paying attention to feelings
another conversation i get into with
mark constantly is
i don't remember what
i said but i remember how i felt
and that's mostly where i live just in
the lands of feelings and constantly
talking to myself the reason why you are
not chasing your big dream is because
you are afraid that it's going to fail
you're afraid that it's not going to
work and what people will say about you
and what you will think about yourself
but what's the alternative it's sitting
on your idea for years never taking your
shot because you're afraid and living
the rest of your life in regret knowing
that you had an opportunity but were too
afraid to take it the way to not have
regrets is to be always taking action to
as soon as you get an idea go do
something about it i had a great podcast
with my friend mark drager a couple
weeks ago a month ago or so where
he was asking me about regret and i used
to always tell this story of
imagine you have a hangnail how much
that hurts and it's all you can think
about when you have a hangnail but if
somebody punches you in the arm you
don't feel the hangnail anymore because
this hurts more right you focus on what
hurts more and suddenly this one doesn't
hurt as much that's how i would use
regret i would always think about
whatever pain that i'm in right now this
thing that i want to do but i'm afraid i
would imagine that this thing is going
to be the best thing of all time that
this video i'm going to make this speech
i'm gonna give this clan i'm gonna make
is gonna be the best of all time and if
i don't do it i'm gonna regret it for
the rest of my life for decades i'm
gonna regret not taking action and so
the pain of doing the thing is the
hangnail and the future paint of regret
for decades is the punch to the arm and
so it inflicts so much pain on me that
then i have to go off and do that thing
and i use that for
over a decade
over a decade that's the lens through
which i made decisions and saw the world
but for the past two years i haven't
done that at all i haven't talked about
it i haven't
done it for myself because i talk about
the things that i live
and i'm thinking why why don't i do that
anymore why don't i
use future regret to fuel me
and i found this because i'm always
taking action because as soon as i get
an idea i do something and so i don't
judge the idea i don't say why me i
don't ponder on the idea i don't i don't
just default to strategizing and
thinking i don't think why did i come up
with this why am i thinking about this i
just do it you get an idea you go off
and do it and that's been my mindset for
the past year and a half two years and
as a result
the breakthrough was
you don't live with regret
if you're always taking action on the
ideas that you have you don't live with
regret you might regret some of the
things you end up doing but most of the
things that you regret and other things
done as the actions undone not undone
not taken the action is not taken you
don't regret the things that you did you
get the things that you didn't do that's
most people right there may be a couple
things that you regret that you did but
for the most part it's the things that
you are too afraid to do that you regret
for the rest of your life and so if
you're constantly doing if you're
constantly taking action if you're
always jumping then you don't have
regrets
and it's been an interesting way that i
now see the world and hopefully you can
learn from as soon as you get an idea
you go off and you do something you do
that you won't have any regrets
everything that you want out of life is
on the other side of your biggest fears
you want something more you know you're
capable of something more you'll come up
with a great reason why you can't do
that something more but really you're
just afraid if you want a breakthrough
if you want that dream life you need to
change the way you think about fear or
it will handicap you for the rest of
your life so my biggest fear is
disappointing people
i'm afraid that whatever i'm gonna do i
might disappoint somebody and that keeps
me playing small and so whenever i can
recognize it then i have to go all in
and do it just to show myself because it
allows you to play in a bigger stage
every time and that big fear you have
is still there it doesn't go away you're
just capable of slaying a bigger dragon
each time so
what used to count as disappointing
people or my fear of disappointing
people might have been going to a coffee
meeting and helping an entrepreneur i
remember one time super clearly that i
was booking a meeting with an
entrepreneur and
i was so worried that i was going to
disappoint her that i was hoping that
she would cancel and the story told
myself was i'm too busy i got all the
stuff to do you know the
realistic
reasons that you can convince yourself
right there weren't stupid reasons they
were realistic but deep down was i'm
just afraid i'm afraid that she's going
to show up and now i'm not going to give
her value it's a deep fear
and then once i went to go meet her it
was amazing i remember sitting in my car
and said wow like an hour and a half ago
i
was hoping that she was going to cancel
on me and this is the greatest thing of
all time right your biggest fears
prevent you from living the life that
you want most of the time you can't
catch it i think we play small by
default i think your greatest fear owns
you and is giving you tons of logical
reasons why you can't do that thing but
whenever you catch it
whenever you do watch the catch and say
i think this is just my fear talking
that means it's go time that means you
have to do it just to teach yourself
that you're able to conquer it and move
to a greater level of success making
money is about solving problems that's
the core of business someone has a
problem you see a solution they pay you
to solve it if you're not making money
it's because you haven't solved a big
enough problem yet so let's use my
youtube channels as an example now we
got so many youtube channels is crazy
i saw a problem i saw a need right i
wanted visual content i wanted to learn
from successful entrepreneurs and i
wanted it done in a visual way i used to
read books a lot because books was the
only way that i was able to get this
information i didn't have mentors to
teach me about business right i had my
parents who were amazing who taught me
how to be human but i didn't have any
face-to-face mentors that i can go to so
i want the books but i'm a visual
learner i'd much rather see it i get a
lot more by seeing simon talk about a
message than by reading his book i just
do it's how i learn and i think a lot of
people are visual learners and so it's
why i started my youtube channel
i'm i started showcasing successful
stories i started sharing my story as
well in the process and it's been that
duality from the beginning of saying
here's where you can learn from
successful people and here's my message
as well so dj plus thought leader mixed
together and here we go and and we've
had success because it solves the
problem because a lot of you have the
same problem my problem is your problem
you want more success around you you
want to be surrounded by these people
just like i did and instead of you
having to watch 40 hours of simon sonic
content to find the best and mush it
together i do it for you i actually
didn't want to even have a youtube
channel i didn't want to do this i wish
you did this if one of you did this i
would just subscribe be great be free
here we go amazing it was it didn't
exist it wasn't out there so i did it
and that's the process
you could scratch your own itch you
could you can see what problems other
people have but success in business
comes from solving other people's
problems you subscribe to this channel
because you like the content because
hopefully hopefully like the content it
adds value to your life it solves the
problem it sets you up for the day
that's why i have this morning espresso
series it's five times a week monday to
friday set you up for the day give you
the shot of energy motivation plus ideas
to help you go off and build your
business this is the problem that i
solve what's the big problem that you
solve the trick to getting yourself into
action mode is to trigger yourself for
success triggering yourself for success
means you've taken the decision making
out of it that as soon as you come up
with an idea you have trained yourself
by default into action mode you see your
brain will always talk you down from
things because it's trying to keep you
safe and it only understands a world
that currently exists that is logical
and practical until you learn to trigger
yourself for success you will constantly
doubt your thoughts your ideas and your
actions this video
is gonna help so today i wanna talk
about this bag right here a lot of you
leave comments or newer fans of the
channel say why is doritos sponsoring
your videos evan why don't you have a
healthier sponsor don't you know what
bad doritos does to your body you should
be promoting healthy living
doritos is not a sponsor guys this is
this is triggering me for success every
single day and this isn't just some tiny
bag it looks small looking back here but
let me bring this up look at that this
is right next to my face look at how big
that bag of doritos is
i have a strategy
and it's a weird strategy so maybe
you'll love it maybe you won't but i
have a strategy called damn the doritos
i look at this bag so i'm sitting this
is how i'm working right i'm not sitting
i'm standing i'm standing on a
trampoline this is my workspace right
now right i'm standing here i'm working
in the court of my eye i got steve jobs
up here and i got i got this giant bag
of doritos all i want to do is eat this
bag all day long i want to destroy this
bag of doritos look at that giant chip
oh
i'm going to start drooling soon i love
it i want to eat that all day long
this bag is here as a reminder of how
great i am this is the mental
conversation inside my head evan you're
awesome you're awesome for not eating
those doritos every day and i want it as
a reminder people say it doesn't take a
lot of willpower
no it it builds for me at least builds
the willpower builds my strength every
time i see that bag of doritos makes me
feel better about myself that i'm not
eating it and i have the strength to
keep going and so i have that here is
when you're
on a diet right this is how it began
when you're on a diet
your friends your family the experts
will say get rid of all the junk food
from your house get rid of it all
because
otherwise you'll be tempted and then
you're going to eat it and then you're
going to ruin your diet i think that is
actually teaching yourself that you suck
you're teaching yourself i'm a weird
duck you're teaching yourself that you
are not strong enough to be around the
thing and so i need to get it out of my
environment the only way that i can
stick to this thing
is if this other stuff is nowhere close
to me i think you're telling yourself
that you suck i think it's a big crutch
and just like when you break your leg
you have a crutch your ultimate goal is
to not have a crutch is to walk it's to
run it's to be stronger than before
right and so as a step one maybe it's
good right as a step one okay fine you
broke your leg you have a crutch
you want to get on a diet you're
addicted to junk food get out of the
house awesome but as soon as you go on
vacation as soon as you go to an office
party as soon as you go to new year's
any kind of party you're going to
destroy the food because you've trained
yourself every day that you suck that
you're not capable i think you're a
genius i think you're stronger than you
think
and so i tested it first with myself and
i thought you know what doritos are my
nemesis right i love doritos
oh my gosh she's looking at that bag so
i went to costco and bought the
giant-sized bag of doritos and said i'm
going to put this on my desk all day
long because damn the doritos because
the doritos are stronger than me i don't
think so
right i'm evan carmichael and same thing
for you
that thing that is holding you that's
that's stronger than you i don't think
so remember who you are
remember how strong you are and that's
what this is here for and it's been
awesome to see people now take this up a
friend of the channel uh leron
who's trying to get off of sugar and he
has this uh coffee cup with a saucer and
he drinks his morning coffee and he put
two packets of sugar on the saucer right
next to the coffee so he pours his
coffee has the sugar right next to it
and he just starts drinking it and puts
it down and looks at the sugar packs and
then just drinks a coffee again and puts
it down looks at the sugar packs and his
wife thinks he's crazy
and he's a little crazy too you got to
be a little bit weird duck but but i
think this is actually how you build
your strength
mark drager another friend of the
channel is addicted to the peak freeze
cookies you know the ones that have the
the red on the inside and the cream in
the middle those are among my favorites
too
and so
his co when he heard this went out and
bought all these boxes of peak frames
and put it on mark's desk and he opened
it up and this is one of my favorite
things to do when whenever i'm around
doritos or something i really love to to
eat not just say oh put that away from
me don't be around me i can't have that
and not just look at it i want to smell
it
so mark took these cookies brought it
right up here peak free cookies right up
here
oh and you can just see the joy on his
face
jess says he's bringing back memories
and just what those cookies are gonna
taste like when they enter his stomach
and just um goodness everywhere right
the smile on his face maybe a little bit
of drool coming out you just ah
and then put the cookies down
and walk away
and how great that makes you feel as a
human to say here's one of my biggest
weaknesses of all time bring it
i own you put it down and walk away
right
i think that's how you actually build
strength by doing those difficult things
by triggering yourself for success every
time i see the doritos back i feel
better about myself i feel stronger
about myself and i want you to do the
same thing if any of you are going to
take on that kind of challenge i want to
hear you i want to follow you i want to
i want to see how your journey is going
because it can be one of the biggest
most important life-changing decisions
that you embark on most people focus on
the problem instead of the solution and
that is why they fail i like to say that
there are a million reasons why your
ideas will never work out and only eight
why they will either way you're right so
it's better to focus on the eight your
heroes the people that you look up to
the people that you love and want to be
like right your heroes
all succeeded with less than what you
currently have right now if they can all
do it so can you the only thing in your
way are your excuses so one of the
things that i love most about
both my wife and my team is that they're
always willing to find a way one of the
things that nina loves most about
herself i had her fill out this form
maybe two years ago of like what do you
love most about yourself and at the top
was she's a fast learner she loves
learning new things she loves taking on
new challenges and i love that i love
that about her and i love that in people
i think you should be a fast learner i
think you should love learning i think
you should always be taking on new
opportunities right now on my youtube
channel i've split up my channel into
eight or nine different channels and
then just recently i split them up again
where we launched a top 10 channel just
for the top 10 videos so the top 10
videos aren't on my main channel anymore
and uh then we're doing an everything
channel where if you just want all the
content it's all on one spot so
it's chaos it's crazy my whole team has
to be restructured and everybody's
taking on new projects and
responsibilities and we were supposed to
have a one month transition phase to do
it
that was the recommendation that was
that was the aggressive recommendation
this is have a one month transition
period and for me one month just as
death it's just that i mean i said okay
great one month but then as i'm into it
on the tuesday of like the first week
like guys we need to launch
like this weekend
need to launch this weekend let's go
right and and there's so many reasons
why it's not going to work and there's
so many problems and yes we're going to
make so many mistakes and people aren't
trained properly and there's more work
and we need to you know we figure out
who wants to do what and how so many
issues awesome let's go
i think about ray for example on my team
who
has been doing all these thumbnails so
i have a i have a set design for my top
10 rules thumbnails that people love and
it's been going like that for years and
i've always been on my team to say
i don't care that everybody thinks our
thumbnails are great they can be better
how do we make them better and so
finally finally after years of testing
we finally found the format that would
win that would that would beat our
original thumbnails and there's minor
differences we zoom in on the face we
got rid of the second logo we make the
text bigger minor differences and then
ray's been going back and updating split
tests doing against our old videos we
have 13 1400 different split tests on
our videos it's crazy i think i split
test more than anybody on youtube so
he's going back and updating all the old
thumbnails
and trying to prove a winner each time
and he's maybe i don't know halfway
through
think about it how many videos we have
on the channel we've got 6 thousand
videos a lot of them are top tens
now with this change i found a new
format
we found a new format a new thumbnail
different color scheme different text
different pictures
different logo new thumbnail format and
we found that it's working and so i said
ray
i know you just changed all the
thumbnails
we got to do it again he's like this is
so exciting let's go i like i love those
guys so much right where most people
what are they they're going to complain
they're going to say i just did all this
work on this other thing right
you don't want to be around people like
that and you definitely don't want to be
that for too many people the problem is
for so many people that's you that's not
even people around you that's you you're
thinking about all the sunk costs that
you put into something you're thinking
about invested so much into this thing
and and now you want me to shift
everything
yep
you need to be on the yep side now you
need to adopt that kind of mindset that
kind of personality that just because i
worked before it doesn't mean it's going
to keep working you find something new
what's better let's go this is what the
whole game is about the number one
biggest thing that you are missing is
momentum you're a genius you've got
michael jordan level talent you are the
best in the world at something but until
you match your effort to your
capabilities your dreams will never
happen so yesterday i had a young
preacher reach out to me on instagram
young
like early teenager reach out to me on
instagram and say hey evan i'm a
preacher i'm trying to get my career
going i want to make youtube videos i
want to spread a message can you watch
my video and give me some feedback
and i love first off i love young
entrepreneurs who are going after it who
are not just sitting there making
excuses as to why they can't because
they don't come from the family they
don't have the right education they know
the right gear to make a video and
here's this guy just takes out his phone
against a simple background poor
lighting doesn't matter right just takes
out his phone starts recording the video
and he's pretty good
right for for a kid who's 14 15 16 years
old he's pretty good he's way better
than i was he's way better than i was
when i started making videos at i don't
know when i started making videos 10
years ago how old am i now 39 29 he's
better at 14 15 16 than i was at 29.
that's amazing i love it but here's the
thing he's only making a video once a
week so i said i love it man but you
gotta you gotta match your actions to
your missions you gotta keep going if
you wanna be the greatest preacher on
the planet you gotta make more content
one to practice right if you're a
thought lead if you're an expert if what
you are creating comes from here
and you just speak it out you need to be
making a video every day every day if
you can freestyle as an artist as a
rapper you should be making a video
every single day now if your videos
require some massive setup not because
it's about the quality of your thought
but it's about fancy stunts or something
that requires a lot more fine but if
it's thought leadership if it's content
that's just coming out of your head
right the quality of your ideas
every single day
once you get better
the more you do it the better you're
gonna get took me 350 videos until i
wasn't completely embarrassed by my own
content right i couldn't watch it back
because i was i was too embarrassed
bad now as i watch my videos it's funny
wherever nina comes in and she's seeing
me watch my videos i always have this
big grin on my face like i'm i'm
cheering myself on like yeah yeah yeah
that's really good and there's
definitely still tons of room to improve
but
it took me 350 videos to before i wasn't
completely embarrassed and now i'm 6 000
or something videos in it's hard to keep
track
your actions have to match your
ambitions so if that's you if you've got
ideas you've got knowledge stop coming
up with excuses
and make the content film it and post
today and again tomorrow and again the
next day and again the next day and when
you're creating so much content
one again you're getting better because
the quantity leads to the quality but
two you get less attached to one video
having to be the thing
so often you make one piece of content
one painting one song one video you make
it and then that has to be the thing
you're getting feedback and you destroy
it if it doesn't take off if this video
doesn't take off great
next
right next next next keep going keep
creating you need momentum
so your actions have to map to your
ambitions right whatever idea you have
in your head you want to be the next
oprah of whatever industry great
let's see it let's see it in the work
let's see it in the energy let's see it
in the output that you were creating
every single day albert einstein once
wrote everybody is a genius but if you
judge a fish by its ability to climb a
tree it will live its whole life
believing that it is stupid that's why
awareness is so important if you are not
happy if you are not fulfilled if you
don't feel like you're making progress
is because you're fish trying to climb a
tree instead of where you should be
which is swimming and if you don't
figure that out and soon you're gonna
live your whole life believing that
you're stupid when you are a genius one
of my favorite stories as i was trying
to launch my youtube channel was i was
trying to learn from different peoples
trying to take in input learn from the
experts i didn't know what i was doing i
was a scared shy
introvert afraid of being in front of
the camera afraid of putting videos up
and so i needed help and i asked for
help and and there was one guy in
particular who has given me a lot of
feedback and help and improving my
channel and then i wanted to take it in
a different direction the advice he gave
me was amazing it was it was helpful
seeing results
and then i wanted to make a video around
believe
i just figured out what my one word was
i found believe i want to make a video
about believe and he didn't like it
i put it together it was six minutes
long and he told me no video on the
internet should be six minutes long you
don't understand how the internet works
nobody's gonna watch this video and it
was really heartbreaking because
this was a mentor of mine so somebody
who was giving me feedback and advice
and and it was working and so he's
telling me that this new thing i was
doing was wrong it would never work that
i don't understand how the internet
works and i didn't know what to do and i
think a younger version of me would have
said okay well something must be wrong
this guy has experience he's in the
industry he wasn't just some random
person on the street he had been making
videos his whole career he's had
successes before
a younger evan would have said okay
i guess it's wrong i should fix it i
should do something else
but because of
me finding my one word having that
self-awareness and feeling like i loved
it like i liked this video
sure it was six and a half minutes but i
liked it
and at the time now in context this
video is gonna be longer than six and a
half minutes but at the time most videos
weren't very long on youtube it was a
different era when i was starting off
and i said you know what i don't care
i'm gonna post it it's about believe i
love it i'm proud of this if nobody else
watches it at least i took my shot and i
put it up
and that video became my best video on
the channel at the time i had my best
video was a hundred thousand views in a
year that was my chris gardner story and
i was so proud of that video put so much
work in and when you hit a hundred
thousand be like ah more so many people
saw this video it's crazy and it took a
year to get there and then this video
within the first month already crossed
100 000 views
[Music]
if you like this video i'm sure you will
like another top 10 of evan carmichael
watch the video next to me i think you
can enjoy continue to believe i will see
you there you don't need money to make
money you need your energy you need your
resourcefulness as soon as you focus on
resources as being the problem